another story were falling this morning
a sheriff's officer was caught on video
threatening to take a man to jail after
jaywalking in Florida Devante Shipman
started recording on a cell phone
shortly after the Jacksonville officer
stopped him last week community
activists believe it happened because
Shipman was quote walking while black an
internal sheriff's department review is
underway
David beg know is in Jacksonville where
he spoke to the 21 year old David good
morning good morning this is the
crosswalk in question Devante Shipman
insists he was walking between the lines
where it was legal but the officer says
Devante didn't have the right of way
because the indicator wasn't blinking in
his favor the officer never cursed in
Devante never put his hands on him and
didn't take him to jail but in the video
the officer is verbally forceful and
Devante wonders why such verbal force
for a minor infraction was it every day
wrong officer the video begins with the
officer sternly telling Devante Shipman
and his friend why he stopped them one
he warned in the crosswalk two there is
a red sign moments later officer Jay s
Bolin threatens to arrest both of them
if they don't walk over to his patrol
car I'm about to put you in jail for
what just being a direct or that's not
disobeying resisting without I'm not
telling you again were you inside of
these crosswalk lines I was just like
this shipment admits he never saw
whether the crosswalk light indicated he
could cross legally there was two cars
that were coming through the
intersection that had to slow down they
had the right away not you what made you
want a video it you got police shootings
and killings from offices and black in
black communities and and that's just
why I feel like it was oh my and I feel
like I needed to be safe to report it do
you feel like this happened because you
were black not entirely I just feel like
it happened because I was just singled
out since February the Jacksonville
sheriff has been using state grant money
to target jaywalking on four specific
streets it's part of an effort to reduce
traffic deaths Shipman was ticketed
about a mile from one of those streets
he was also cited for not having his
driver's license
in the state of Florida you have to have
an ID card on you identifying who you
are but that's not what Florida law says
according to the statute used by the
officer to ticket Devante it applies to
drivers not pedestrians attorney Michael
Gottlieb who has defended police in
court says officer Boland was
overzealous but he also thinks Shipman
cell phone and his attitude added to the
tension you're already videoing it we
can see the officers attitude take it to
court show the judge the right thing
will happen in court officer Boland
never mentions Devon tase race in the
video we called officer Boland to get
his side of the story but he hasn't
called us back is up this morning David
Devante plans to contest his $198
tickets in court and in the video you
actually hear the officers say quote I
really hope you take that option because
I promise you I will be there David
thanks